kristan Nelson I think is a great
example of what happens when you go to
work for Donald Trump he is the great
reputation killer I mean here's this
woman who you know was a reasonably
admired bureaucrat and for the rest of
her life
for the rest of her life people will
look at her and think oh that's the
woman who put children in cages well
maybe because of media people like you
ly Jeff
joining me now is Laura Logan former CBS
reporter 60 minutes correspondent
reported all over the world about really
really complicated issues in a fair
fashion
Laura it's great to see on this issue of
immigration something I've written
reporting on it for like 20 years I mean
just all the changes all the stresses on
the border but reporters are basically
now just advocates for their own self
created NGO it's unbelievable Laura
there are a few journalistic questions
that I would want asked right if I was
reporting on this which is where did the
previous administrations
put the children that they detained I
mean they have also put them in prison
right how do I know this because as a
reporter for 60 minutes I was approached
by UNICEF I had meetings with them about
doing a story they were so concerned
about the number of children in
detention under the Obama administration
that they asked 60 minutes to look into
doing a story on it so this isn't the
first time it's happened but it's not
being treated the same and anytime
there's not a consistent standard in the
reporting that's a red flag for me as a
journalist and lera and the root causes
of this also not being covered why this
is happening why there's this flow into
the country why the caravans so none of
that is really being looked at
everyone's empathizing with the poor
families and I understand that but
that's not really that's not real
empathizing is not it's not really
reporting it's empathizing it's
something completely different I also
want to get your thoughts
lera on the president's decision to skip
the annual White House Correspondents
Dinner third year in the row in a row
now what about that he's going to hold a
rally instead well why would the
president want to go to a dinner which
is full of a room full of people who
have made it clear that
many of whom have made it clear that
they want him removed from office and
that they don't just hate him they see
him as unfit and they've made you know
this is not a two-way street if the
press is allowed to criticize Donald
Trump then why isn't he allowed to
criticize the press that's the way I
look at this this is about what the
First Amendment is about and this is
about everybody's rights so you know if
would you go to a dinner with a with a
bunch of people who made it very clear
that they were your enemies I mean it
doesn't make sense for him it's not
going to change the coverage
I mean I've skipped the dinner for the
past few years because they've become
very partisan Affairs and they make a
lot of people uncomfortable they're not
what they used to be in journalists and
journalistic organizations in this
country need to stand up and go back to
what we're supposed to be at our core
and if they if they want to be critical
of the president which is part of our
responsibility and duty as journalists
well then they you know they don't get
to weep about it when he's critical in
return and this is very consistent with
Donald Trump as a leader it's a very
bold move he doesn't care that he's
snubbing the press I love it he doesn't
care yeah I love it I haven't been in a
number of years
no interesting going back we really
appreciate your perspective on this